since appearing in 1984 Freddy Krueger
has become an iconic horror villain but
how did he go from a child killer and a
grimy Christmas sweater to Jason
Voorhees puppeteer he is the breakdown
of the entire original Nightmare on Elm
Street story our first real introduction
to Freddy Krueger comes in the form of a
dream that high school attina has one
terrible night
she later shares the experience with her
friends Nancy Glen and rod who have all
been having the same dreams about the
same man it soon revealed that the
monster in their dreams was once a human
child killer who became the target of
the town's parents after the legal
system failed to bring him to justice
honey because mommy killed him somehow
Krueger figured out how to live on in
the dream world and now he wants to
murder the children of the parents who
killed him
luckily Nancy eventually defeats him
after dragging him into the real world
after their confrontation
Nancy walks outside her house and all
seems well her friends are alive and
everything is sunshine and roses until
the car suddenly turns into a Freddy
'mobile and traps everyone inside five
years later in Freddy's revenge a kid
named Jesse and his family move into
Nancy's old house on Elm Street and an
entirely new cast of characters are
tormented by Freddy Jesse's dreams of
Freddy are little different from Nancy's
in that Jesse never really finds himself
in any danger of being killed but when
he and his friend Lisa find Nancy's old
diary he realizes exactly who is up
against in order to stay awake Jesse
starts to wander around town at night he
winds up in an SMM bar where his
leather-clad gym coach catches him
drinking a beer and takes him back to
the school to punish him there jesse
experiences his first freddy possession
and he slashes his teacher to death in
the showers things come to a head at
least his pool party where freddy
actually burst through jesse stomach
kills his friends and then goes after
everyone at the pool Lisa tells Freddy
that she loves Jesse and kisses him
which prompts Freddy to burst into
flames a Nightmare on Elm Street three
dream warriors brings Nancy back to the
franchise only now she's an insane
therapist at a psychiatric hospital also
at the hospital is Kristen a teenager
who has the ability to bring other
people into her own dreams which
comes in handy when fighting Freddie its
drawing this movie that a nun named
sister Mary Helena
reveals that the only way to defeat
Freddie is to find his remains and
buried them on hallowed ground
Nancy becomes Freddie's final victim
before his bones are able to finally be
put to rest
destroying his monstrous form in the
real world and how's this for a plot
twist that's helpful none was Freddie's
mom all along a year later in Nightmare
on Elm Street 5 the dream master dream
warrior Kristen is convinced that
Freddie Krueger is still out there and
looking to take down her and her friends
since that's kind of his thing as it
turns out she is after killing the other
two dream warriors survivors Freddie
takes aim at Kristen's new friends
including a girl named Alice who knows a
powerful rhyme called the dream master
Freddie finally kills Kristen but before
she dies she's able to pass her dream
power on to Alice Alice confronts Freddy
and remembering that dream master rhyme
she shows the monster his reflection
[Music]
defeated Freddy is torn apart by the
very soul sit trapped
releasing the ghost of every trapped
murdered child in my Marin Elm Street 5
the dream child Alice discovers she's
pregnant but this isn't your average
pregnancy Freddy is somehow feeding her
baby with the souls of his victims
through all of this
Alice keeps seeing a young boy named
Jacob who turns out to be an older
version of her unborn child
Alice discovers that the body of
Freddie's mother Amanda is still in the
asylum and now the only way to defeat
Freddy is to release Amanda soul after a
little trickery by young Catrin trial
Jacob Amanda and Jacob are able to trap
Freddy soul by turning him into an
adorable baby in Freddy stared at the
final nightmare a decade has passed and
in Springwood Ohio the entire population
of minors has been mysteriously wiped
out only one remains John Doe who Freddy
sends out into the world in order to
retrieve more souls for him outside of
the city John comes across a youth
shelter where he meets Maggie and a new
group of future victims John and Maggie
have dreams involving the same girl
which drives them back to spring wood
John Maggie and the other teens take
refuge at the old Elm Street house where
Freddy attacks each one Maggie
eventually realizes that Freddy is
actually her father I know who I am
although you could have brought me out
with the help of another shelter
employee named doc is discovered that
Freddie has been kept alive by dream
demons and the only way to kill him once
and for all is to drag him into the real
world
Maggie brings him into the real world
and throws a bunch of weapons at him in
3d then stabs him with his own glove and
blows him up in Freddy vs. Jason it
becomes clear to Freddy the only way to
make a real comeback is if the teenage
residents of spring would remember how
terrifying hears Freddy decides to
resurrect Jason Voorhees so the
mask-wearing murderer can kill a bunch
of kids in Freddy's name things go
mostly as planned as Jason goes after
local girl Laurie and her friends as a
party in a cornfield Jason goes all out
not only satiating his own relentless
desire to kill but taking all the fun
out of it for Freddy as well well Laurie
and her friends try to figure out a way
to kill both monsters Freddy becomes
increasingly more annoyed with Jason's
and ability to be controlled
Laurie figures out how to pull Freddy
into the real world and Krueger and
Voorhees face off in the horror fight of
the century Wes Craven's new nightmare
isn't exactly part of the continuity but
there are enough nods to the original
franchise that its presence on the
timeline makes sense essentially it
takes place in the real world and had a
Langenkamp and Robert Englund play
themselves actors who have been offered
roles in a new Nightmare on Elm Street
movie however the world of Nightmare
starts creeping into Heather's real life
her sleepwalking son Dylan has dreams of
Freddy after he kills Heather's husband
demon Freddy goes after Dylan and the
only person who can stop him is Heather
as Nancy
Heather plays the part and goes to the
Elm Street house where demon Freddy has
Dillon held captive where the Dylan's
help Heather eventually manages to
overpower demon Freddy and locks him in
a furnace but he burns to death
considering that the next Nightmare film
was a full-on reboot it looks like this
death finally took four old Freddy
Krueger check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos buy your favorite horror movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one